welcome
to our panel on um
abolition and black religions
and u.s empire with a distinguished
guest sylvester johnson vincent lloyd
and joshua dupler
and professor doobler we have to
apologize for the
error in the poster which maybe you
didn't even notice
but uh as i'm looking at your face
i think we had you at the wrong
institution um
josh stupler is in fact associate
professor of religion at the university
of rochester
where he directs the rochester education
justice initiative
he's author of down in the chapel
religious life
in an american prison published in 2013
and co-editor of the recent volume
religion
law usa which i'm proud to have an essay
in
and uh also co-author with vincent lloyd
break
every yoke religion power and the end of
mass incarceration
which much of our class read for today
and
sparked a very stimulating discussion um
and it's a book that looks to marshal
religious resources towards
prison abolition um
vincent lloyd is associate professor of
theology and
religious studies at villanova
university and co-author with josh
dubler of the book break every yoke um
lloyd also co-edits the journal
political theology
has written at least five earlier books
i don't know how you write so many books
vincent
um and it has edited or co-edited five
collections
of uh essays and four special issues of
scholarly journals
his newest book as i understand it is
forthcoming from yale university press
titled black dignity of philosophy
it examines the moral vocabulary of
black lives matter with chapters
organized by hashtags i
am just i pulled this from your site and
i'm so intrigued i can't wait to read it
um sylvester johnson
uh last in my list of introductions but
by no means least is professor of
religion
and founding director of the virginia
tech center for the humanities
he also serves as assistant vice provost
for the humanities at virginia tech and
executive director of the university's
tech for humanity initiative
johnson's books include the myth of ham
in 19th century american christianity
and african american religions hundred
to two thousand um now it's my turn to
hold the book up
uh which
uh is an award-winning interpretation of
five centuries of democracy colonialism
and freedom in the atlantic world and
the other portion of our class
read professor johnson's book for today
um sylvester has also co-edited the fbi
and religion faith and national security
before
and after 9 11 and he and i are now
working together on a co-edited book on
the topic of religion and
u.s empire so i'm very proud to
introduce
this distinguished panel of speakers for
tonight and uh we had a fun time in our
seminar this afternoon putting these
books into conversation
and so we our goal is to continue that
conversation
um in this slightly more public format
this evening zarina take it away
hi everybody and thanks so much to our
wonderful
uh colleagues for joining our class and
for the friends who are joining
um as well from yale and beyond for this
conversation we're really just so
excited i have to say this was i think
our liveliest
discussion and um you you've renewed
my belief in the possibility of a
healthy zoom seminar discussion with
with these just amazing texts that have
been so stimulating for us
so i thought we'd begin um you know by
just thinking for a moment about why we
paired the text together and if you
could talk to us a little bit about the
genres of the text which was actually a
really
interesting um place for us to begin our
earlier discussion in class
uh you know uh of course semester
johnson's wonderful book
is a macro history it's uh both texts
are actually genealogical studies
and so they're drawing on foucault and
and and and and
allowing us to kind of you know
interrogate categories that we might
assume are settled
in particular ways um but of course the
scope of
of uh african-american religions is is
over five centuries
it's a transnational story
um you know an incredible archive
uh but of course it's not simply a kind
of you know
history of ideas or history of religions
it's in fact much more complex
really the encounters um and the ways in
which space
time discourses uh are kind of reordered
by the
imperial encounters um between black
peoples and and
and uh empires and and and then of
course uh
we were talking about break every yoke
as a very different kind of genre so
this is
while african-american religions is kind
of a slow
careful methodical deep read that even i
think this and i were agreeing that we
both read it several times and every
time we get something new
out of it right um and it's certainly
gonna marinate on those ideas and they
come to you
slowly over and over again break every
yoke
is written in in a really urgent
register and i think we
thought amongst ourselves that this
might be best characterized as a kind of
polemical text
um there it is genealogical it is it
does uh
do do that similar kind of analytical
work in unsettling some categories and
making us think through
the ways in which mass incarceration
becomes the answer to a set of questions
that are
historically contingent um and there is
a kind of
chapter that is a sort of history of
ideas in a way or an intellectual
history
but this is a polemical work that that
reads very
urgent uh reason it is written and reads
with a kind of political urgency that's
also a call
really for us to think about how
religion
might be a resource for those of us uh
who want to
um work of abolition so i
i thought we might begin by just asking
you to talk a little bit about
um the projects and the scale of the
projects
uh and and what brought you to the
projects and and
and to think about the choice to write
in these two different registers whether
it's
macro history that comes touches down on
micro histories and certain moments to
make a particular argument
uh versus the kind of i think we were
characterizing as a kind of polemical
argument that has a kind of scholar
activist
energy energy to it although obviously
the political commitments of both books
are certainly
overlapping so do you want to begin
sylvester with your book
sure i will uh so thanks first of all
for the invitation i'm really delighted
to
be able to engage with all of you and
uh certainly i appreciate you talking
about our work for certainly
your students know very well the work
that though zarina
teaser that you both have produced has
been very elucidating for us all
and uh so thank you again
there are a couple of things that i
would identify as
high level motivations for this book and
one of those
was the answers i had in though trying
to understand
and then to clarify for readers
the experience of colonialism which is
which has most frequently been read in a
very narrow way
as something that that has not applied
to african descended peoples in
the americas and particularly in north
america
and what i wanted to show is that
colonialism
is a very complicated superstructure
that
has had many different kinds of
iterations uh that doesn't look
only one way and
certainly has something that is
foundational
that constitutes it and that has a lot
to do
with the formations of what has come to
be called african-american religions
and the second motivation was to
understand and to
and also help to clarify in an explicit
fashion
the relationship between the things that
we publicly
value and hold dear so democracy is one
of those
freedom is another and with
the relationship between those things
and things that we claim to abhor
and to hold and disdain colonialism
being especially indicative of that
because often not always but often
the problems that we identify as
reprehensible or often
connected to things that we cherish
and it makes it very difficult to
address those problems
if we're not very honest about
how we have inherited what we have and
so
the the second part of that aim was to
explain
how it is that democratic governance
has emerged in large measure
due to colonial practices so those are a
couple of things that
that motivate the writing of the text
uh and then josh or vincent do either of
you or both of you want to
want to tell us a little bit about the
story behind rick and ryoke
shell ivinson sure and i can
add a couple things sure
um um like sylvester said uh really
grateful
to to be here um this is a book that
came out of a working group
um that uh we founded in 2012
when uh we found ourselves suddenly in
western new york
vincent was teaching at syracuse i was
teaching
at rochester um
the point of departure was to think
about
burnt over district religion and
abolition
um interestingly so so tisa when you
read the
uh the subtitle you read was the
original subtitle the book that in some
sense gives a sense of
of the of the process that that we made
right so
the book began as an intervention uh an
intended intervention
into um the what we saw
as the kind of really dominant
narratives about uh
mass incarceration so thinking about the
last 50 years of american history and
the middle chapters of the book are an
attempt to think religion
you know how did we get here in relation
to the stories about race
economics and politics interestingly and
called into relief by president company
in this context
uh you know empire is a light motif it's
not featured
um and i would say um
you know in the last few years the like
critical prison studies has has
really turned to empire uh not that it
wasn't there before but thinking of
uh hernandez's city of inmates the
steward traitors badges without borders
so
it might have been at a later time we
would have attended more directly to
empire
but so the middle book is an attempt to
kind of tell gesture toward
um the religious elements of how
mass incarceration emerged uh and and
became enshrined at the level of
political discourse
um at the level of um
local congregations and grassroots
organizing and at the level of
the religion of incarcerated people
that's the middle part of the book
which is um in its way attempting to be
genealogical
but then um you know the book uh i think
the shift that that overtook us then
which has overtaken
um the critical discourse about prisons
more more generally in this country
in the years that we wrote the book um
uh in the in the course of writing the
book we we became committed to
uh abolition um as the necessary
uh approach to um if we're gonna
uh squeeze out any kind of of justice
from from
um from the contemporary order of things
so
the the the parts uh the first the
beginning of the book and the end of the
book the kind of
framing chapters are a brief
uh for abolition why abolition and not
reform kind of
writing to um people who might
have been turned on by the new jim crow
and and explaining why
abolition was the right framework uh and
and and
trying to show the use of thinking about
religion in that in that context
um and then the final all right the
final chapter
is kind of showing people on the ground
who are doing uh uh
abolitionist organizing uh under the
banner of certain religions or
spirituality so
i think i don't know about polemic um i
would say like
in some ways a a friendly amendment
to a really robust critical discourse
that is
that intersects with all sorts of
movement activity
uh an exhortation like um
uh yeah that's how i might characterize
it
what did you what would you say vincent
just to i underscored two points
i think as a pragmatic political
intervention we were thinking of
uh secular prison abolitionists
uh who uh have
um uh no taste or no error for
religion or spirituality uh and perhaps
an allergy to religion or spirituality
and we were thinking of
uh religious communities looking uh for
ways you know inspired by the new jim
grow inspired by
brian stevenson looking for ways to
engage on these issues and
um our intention was to to tell stories
that would uh make clear why
uh religious communities and secular
prison abolitionists could work
um could and should work together toward
uh prison abolition
but in doing that i mean i think as josh
started out by saying
we were very much thinking about a
particular uh
american tradition uh that
i was rooted in um second great
awakening and uh
slave uh movement to abolish slavery
uh where political the political and the
theological or intertwined
uh and uh thinking about the ways that
that tradition continues into the
present in a way that is no longer
attached to christianity but
attached to broader spiritual currents
um
and um eclectic uh religious
um uh engagements in images and effects
um and you know trying to make that
tradition present
uh for for today
thank you this is so helpful um and
interesting to hear you guys talk about
these books
um i wanted to say before i i have a
question i
really desperately want to raise but uh
before i say that for the students in
our class
i meant to say this earlier i know some
of you have
questions you want to raise um
yeah maybe jessica maybe um david
maybe others but if you want to raise a
question including people i just named
um
please let us know in the chat and we'll
we'll call on you um
zarina and i are gonna just turn into
moderators
after this next question of mine so we
want
unless you guys don't have anything to
say which i know is not true
uh we want the student we want you guys
to be raising the questions
um so but my question is about the sign
of freedom
which i think is present in very
different ways in both books
and for um
vincent and josh really may be it's
a kind of taken for granted or a stable
signifier right isn't freedom the kind
of the goal of abolition
um and uh but in
sylvester in your book it's a more
troubled concept
right uh as you were mentioning even in
your introduction a few minutes ago
uh i was really struck on this reading
as i told
some of the students in the class um
on the very last page how you conclude
the book
and you write about how african-american
religions have long operated under the
sign of freedom
for very good reason but then you say in
the final paragraph
um throughout this account of
african-american religions i've sought
to render the ambivalence
of freedom by making visible its linkage
to colonialism
so you know you already started
answering this in your earlier comments
but how much of the book is aimed at
getting people to trouble the concept of
freedom
um as it operates maybe sometimes
as as it's forged by empire and maybe
operates
in service of imperialism and how do
we think about those complexities
because even
as um
i in the prior paragraph where you say
african-american religion has operated
under the sign of
freedom i don't see that as a criticism
of african-american religion i see that
as a kind of
observation and maybe a necessity for it
to operate but then
when you are thinking with other
scholars who
are critical of kind of enlightenment
principles such as freedom and how
the kind of maybe subject formation and
agency formation that it assumes
um what does that mean for understanding
african american religion and i saw that
so much more as the point of the book
reading through this time than i had
previously so
i want you to kind of unpack that for us
a little bit and then
uh maybe let's let sylvester do that
first and then let
uh josh and vincent respond
and think about if freedom do you
also think of freedom as a troubled uh
category in some
sense if so it doesn't that it doesn't
show up in this book but how do you
think about this book
that problem in relation to the history
that sylvester provides
yeah well thanks for the questions i
think a couple of examples
i'll use to point to scholars who
not found very helpful for
trying to understand what's going on
with these with these structures
uh so orlando patterson has written
freedom of making western culture
in which he interprets the history of
freedom
by attending to the material structures
and political and social systems
that give it substance that make it
socially real and one of the things that
he argues that i
i'm persuaded by is that freedom is not
some
um it's not some
otherworldly divine or sublime
reality that is handed to us
in a fashion that
is somehow fundamentally at odds
with systems of domination that just as
we think of slavery
as being a social
historical politically situated reality
most most people
most experts would agree that
slavery is not inside of people it's not
something that's naturally there
which aristotle argued it was that there
were some people who were naturally
slave people and other who were
naturally free
uh i don't i don't agree with that
aristotelian view and
i think it's fair to say most experts
would reject that they would say no
slavery is a system that people invented
uh it depends upon certain kinds of
practices
it depends upon systems of domination
and as such it should not be naturalized
and the same way patterson makes that
analysis for freedom
and i think he's right about that uh a
point to see your heartsman so her
scenes of subjection
she tries to show by thinking of freedom
as some naturalistic
state that is just operating
that only needs restraints removed in
order for that human
subject to be fulfilled is actually
a fictitious way of understanding
freedom and so she points to
the period of emancipation
and the ensuing years of emancipation to
show why that idea
that people had freedom naturally in
them
was flawed and that if you could just
remove constraints
uh that they would flourish and she
points to the fact that millions of
people
around three and a half million people
in the us were suddenly
thrown out into a life of so-called
freedom without
the material resources
and the structural systems of support
that enabled
uh what appeared to be the free lives of
white people
and what she tries to demonstrate is
that
what we call freedom is really a very
complicated system of privileges
of socially constructed liberties of
access to capital and other forms of
resources social resources
and that is it's not some natural thing
and it actually
often results really from the kinds of
obligations that in here
in social relationships so governments
ideally are obligated to provide certain
things for people
parents ideally are obligated to provide
care for children
uh and that in a human society people
are obligated
to act and
accord themselves or conduct themselves
in a certain way with respect to other
people
and and that gives rise to things that
we call freedom but it's certainly not a
natural
kind of thing it's something that it
depends on social systems and
institutions
and so
[Music]
what i'm what i try to show is that
by making freedom
as this unconditioned naturalistic
kind of reality uh the sign
the the ultimate meaning of the kinds of
pursuits
that we like to claim as the desired
outcome
in a democratic society
what has happened with the legacy of
freedom
and the traditions about it that we've
inherited
is that it makes it difficult to
understand
that what we really need are is the
right balance
of obligations of access to resources of
support
so just as people voluntarily
give up what we might colloquially call
freedom in order to get into a marriage
for example
where they become extraordinarily
obligated to other people
in order to gain something that they
think is valuable
uh so also i think we need to understand
how
our our social and political systems
really do become enabled because
of obligations that we might
agree upon as being reasonable you could
think of anything access to health care
for example or the right to have
education
it depends upon certain obligations it's
not it's not the simplistic removal of
constraints
it is rather structuring systems of
support and obligation to achieve
outcomes that would be broadly
beneficial
and so you could call that demon trying
to demythologize freedom
if you will i think that those are
our very foundational contributions of
the work of patterson
and of hartman that i have learned from
and that i tried to apply to explaining
the relationship that develops
over many centuries across colonialism
and democracy and freedom
and and i do that not to claim that
if we could just get rid of freedom the
world would be a better place
you know i don't i don't believe that
that's not the argument of the book
and i'm certainly i certainly
uh i'm not an expert on abolition that's
vincent
and josh we're going to talk about that
but i certainly am a supportive
supporter of the abolition movement and
of the pursuit to liberate people
from carceral systems so if you ask me
well sylvester is
is is freedom of bad things that no
that's that's not actually the point of
the argument i don't think freedom is a
bad thing
i think we need to demythologize
our understanding of these systems and
if we can understand
that that what we're calling freedom is
actually a set of socially and
politically structured conditions
that are made possible through a mix of
obligations
then we can talk about why we need
to be obligated to ensure
that resources and that services
and support systems are provided broadly
in order for people to have desirable
outcomes that will allow human
flourishing
so uh i can see the cue is already
filling up with people students who want
to ask questions but i just before we
turn it to josh and vincent with the
same question i mean so if i can just
read a passage from
page 225 because i uh i i take your
point josh that this is a exhortation
and not a polemic i mean
we're not wedded to that word but i
think what i was trying to get at and i
certainly don't think
polemic is a bad word i mean uh my
advisor sherman jackson wrote
uh islam and the black american which
was a really influential
uh polemical text um and so i you know i
just think it's a provocation in certain
ways so on page 225
you write uh you're talking about your
previous examples
these are preceding examples are are
they preceding examples religious or are
they secular
are they abolitionist or are they
reformist though we eagerly tackle such
questions in our seminars
we are uninterested in adjudicating them
adjudicating them here
we can see that there is danger
analytically in allowing the category of
religion to grow too capacious
and then you have some quotes from smith
and others uh talking that saying
something that like if all is religion
then we've learned nothing
analogously uh and of substantially
higher stakes and as much as evolution's
power stems from its
categorical no to human caging and human
disposability
we understand how the refusal to police
the boundary between abolition
and not evolution can lead to
abolition's co-optation and innervation
and so in that sense to me what i was
hearing was that
in that in that context of the threat of
co-optation
liberation for you has to be a a guarded
category and a stable category in a way
that it doesn't need to be
or or isn't in sylvester's book but it
but it did bring up for us thought
questions and i think the students will
raise these two
around many of the analytical categories
that you're using in the book
um uh whether it's the secular religious
and
and ritual and others which i just want
you if you just talk a little bit about
you know you're thinking around these
lay versus analytical categories and how
you're using
to make this very strong argument
i'll say something about freedom and
josh can talk about religion um
thank you and uh thanks for the the the
questions
i i don't know so i probably have views
on this that go beyond the scope of the
of the book uh but i mean i think in the
book
josh and i follow jeff stout's uh
gifford lectures and thinking about
um freedom as non-domination as part of
a civic republican tradition
exemplified by phillip pettit and others
uh in political theory um
where the the prison is an image that
stands for
uh the uh stands for something bigger
here
uh and but an image that um uh
when we reflect on it we learned
something about uh
the workings of the world uh where uh
the the domination of the
uh the prison cell like the domination
of the master over the slave in the the
other
iconic image of of domination um uh
is one that uh stands for a system of
domination
uh and uh not just one system but
interlocking systems of domination
uh which in the context of break every
okay we're talking about is
carcerologics and the systems of uh
domination that
uh follow the logic of the of the prison
uh and the the goal right is
uh to get out of the prison cell which
in this sort of scaled-up
version is to get out of carceral logics
which is to
abolish uh all uh pre all
systems that follow the logic of of the
of the prison
to achieve freedom uh in that sense uh
and
i mean that's an extensive vision of the
abolition uh
maybe an impossible vision of the
abolition but where we want to work that
impossibility to name that impossibility
and to name that as
uh as the the goal uh and
to do so i think more at a greater than
rhetorical level right to say this is
uh if our if our desire is for freedom
uh then
we can't leave intact any uh system of
of
uh uh domination that has this carceral
structure
um and we need to start with the prison
and uh work from there to see what it
what
what it interlocks with uh and attack
those
yeah thanks for for the question um
i i think we like uh the jeff stout
reference right i think we're pretty
um our approach is pretty pragmatic and
at the same time
maybe with um maybe like a bit
christian in a kind of uh humility
right so like um you know uh i go out on
the streets when we're protesting in
this town and you know and
people chant about you know putting the
killer cops in jail right and so
um that's the kind of horizon of what
justice looks like
at this point and i think the the kind
of exhortation that we
um are offering in our book like we're
hesitant to
to posit a vision of of liberty or
freedom with an understanding
analogous to uh um uh what sylvester is
saying
um that uh our notions uh you know just
as our notion of freedom needs to be
you know decolonized um it needs to be
decarcerated
so i don't think we have much to say
about freedom
right i mean the category we do work
with right is justice
right and the story we tell about
justice is it's a modest
story right it's just about the story of
how the justice
the justice of the civil rights movement
uh was shrunken down
to become the justice of the criminal
justice system
where throwing the bad people in the
cage is the kind of most we can imagine
if i were to tell a similar story about
freedom i might think about the you know
locating
telling again a more modest story than
the kind of grand sweep about
uh empire and the enlightenment that
sylvester tells i might think about how
freedom seems to mean three things these
days right freedom is like
the eagle that brings american violence
abroad and that we identify with
freedom is freedom of my property a
non-intervention i'm entitled to every
dollar i make you can't take
my taxes and give it to the undeserving
and freedom
the freedom to choose between coke and
pepsi in the marketplace right and so it
would seem like those are the dominant
frameworks of freedom now
and what we would i think our project as
a compliment to sylvester's
if he's demythologizing i think our
instinct is or our you know the
exhortation is one of
toward re-mythologizing right so here we
are
freedom is are these three things that
have nothing to do with freedom that are
embedded in domination
how do we get to a freedom that's worthy
of the category
right and the hunch of the book right is
that
um well we have these uh we have these
religious practices and we have this
kind of religious
order and we have these religious
narratives and they give us resources
the resources they offer aren't pure
they're sullied with the all the kinds
of histories that we're talking about
but
but i think yeah i think the the wit
like the the
the in the will to re-mythologize rather
than de-mythologize
that's beautifully put so we have so
many questions coming in from students
so
uh let's start with alicia
hi uh thank you so much everybody uh for
coming to speak with us
i just finished reading uh break every
yoke
and i was really happy to read it
because
in addition to being a student i am also
an abolitionist myself
and i'm doing grassroots community
organizing
um both with religious communities as a
muslim and also
outside of that and these are like
questions that we
um on the ground are actively
negotiating
um but one of the questions i had was
kind of in the same vein of what was
just talked about
um thinking about
what remit re-mythologizing
these ideas would look like um kind of
in practice so
particularly i'm interested in how
creating this abolition movement that
combines both religious folks and
irreligious folks
how do you create a common language
between
different religions and between folks
who are religious and folks who are
irreligious so how do you create a
common language through which
organizers can operate and how you do
that in a way that doesn't just kind of
default to like
particular values of protestantism and
whiteness
i'll take vincent should i take a so i'm
i'm not um
i would trust you to answer this
question at least alicia uh
more than answering myself um right but
i mean one of the things that was really
encouraging
um uh as like you know the book started
as this like
we want to see this kind of thing and by
the time we finish the book
there was a lot more of the thing we
wanted to see right so i'm thinking of
you know 2018 believer's bailout um
you know on the model of of of bailing
out uh
black mamas for mother's day bailing out
people for ramadan
right um i i
i've never organized uh a closet right
so i mean but
um i mean i would from the organizers
that i read right i would think that
um if you know they're different
overlapping communities
and uh religious frameworks can mobilize
in in particular communities that can
then um
uh you know be in coalition with other
communities who don't share those
languages right so
on the framework that you know i
personally might have something
i might be have resources i could draw
on to kind of wake
uh some jewish communities up right um
uh but then i mean that that's simply so
i don't think one has to
uh resort to only a single language that
can be include everyone
um but then that still leaves your kind
of your basic question about
we do need those categories we do need
those movement categories
and um probably if you can make a
critique of our book it's that we end up
for pragmatic reasons kind of
acquiescing to like
protestantism with the sense that like
that's where the big game is
in this particular culture uh that we
find ourselves right like that's where
you already have this ideological
infrastructure there
vincent would that be a fair critique of
buster do i get us wrong
yeah i mean so maybe to address in a
different
wait um oh sorry my internet is having a
little problem here
um no i mean i i think that very
modestly we're just trying to build a
repertoire of stories
uh that some of which could uh be useful
as resources
and some of which might not be uh in um
and uh you know model what building that
repertoire of stories historical and
contemporary stories
looks like um and yeah i mean
it feels like in um
you know rather than coming in with
norms
or concepts um prescriptively
um having uh
locating a tradition and telling stories
from that tradition
and helping others see themselves um
uh as a part uh
part of that tradition flowing uh from
it and
flowing forward in the in the direction
of justice
that's a modest goal and um i mean some
of that has
some of that tradition has protestant
stuff attached to it it also has other
stuff attached to it and
everyone in that tradition negotiates
their their their way in
in different ways and finds different
resources
useful and not useful so i think we're
going to take two questions at once so
that you can
answer it looks like i don't want us to
get bogged down we've got we've got a
long line here so why don't we have um
jessica and skyler both share a question
and then
um any of you can respond as you wish
sure um thank you everyone for for being
on the panel and especially to
professors floyd and doogler um reading
break every oak was
um really good for me on a personal
level
so thank you um the question that i have
came out of our class discussion this
afternoon we were
talking through the possible alignments
between
break every yoke and african-american
religions around the question of how
the notion of like the secular is
employed in each
um and for me i just sort of wondered
aloud if
they might align under the framework of
gerard hickman's
cosmography um in black prometheus
thinking about his notion of modernity
um
and i guess therefore the secular not as
like a break from the sacred but
um a remapping of the sacred um and that
seemed to me
implicitly maybe to open up the
possibility of
employing something like religion toward
abolition or
the term like spirit of abolition um
so i guess the question is um what were
your working definitions of the secular
in each of your works
um and do you see them interacting with
with hickman at all skylar
um my question goes on i'm great with
that um because my
question is around how the category of
religion
is operating um and
you started touching on it in your
response to alicia's question
um but thinking about in break every
yoke
um the
the category of religion is being used
but the the framework
is primarily uh this protestant
christianity and so how to build
coalition with
a multitude of religions when the
frameworks being
outlined are uh using primarily
christian language
etc and if you could speak more
to that i knew you made a comment about
acquiescing to kind of
the dominant norms but if you could say
a little bit more about how you see the
category of religion
operating
vincent you want to do secular and i'll
do religion
okay
you can go first well
can i can i help by being very specific
so i'm just going to read on page 213
you say to the growing vocabulary maybe
this goes also to alicia's question
about about um
a common vocabulary for for for
organizers and activists
it says to the growing vocabulary of
nominally
secular rituals so i want to know about
nominally and secular in this sentence
the occupation the disruption the dying
the jail vigil we may add the mass the
pilgrimage to passover cedar
some of these rituals will necessarily
take place in houses of worship or in
the home
but those with the most inflammatory
potential will take place in the streets
um and then you go on so right there is
a great example of where
the word nominally and secular
got us stuck on what you mean sure so i
mean
i think we're interested in the the ways
uh in
uh secularism as an ideology that uh
excludes or manages uh religious
uh beliefs and practices in a particular
discourse uh and
the way that secularism is uh as an
ideology is entangled with other
ideologies
um of uh racism and patriarchy
and uh capitalism uh and
carceral uh logics that um
secularism uh in the way that
it um uh flattens justice into law
and order like the the in the in the way
that secularism
um flattens the uh just
flattens the aspirational uh um
uh dimensions of justice into um
uh getting even um
there are connotations of secularism
that that fit well with
uh and that are inextricable from uh a
secularist uh
ideology uh so uh
challenging um
that uh uh secularism and and naming the
connections between our current
um uh uh uh practices
and uh effects that are nominally
secular that
um most people wouldn't name as
religious uh and they're
um obviously religious forbearers uh
naming that connection is doing critical
work right because it's challenging the
idea right it's
um doing a kind of unmasking uh sort of
work that opens up the potential
that provincializes the secular that
opens up the potential to
uh think otherwise than secularism
as an ideology um
so yeah those are
yeah if i had to say you know um i would
say we use these categories um
opportunistically right um
and uh in you know in in writing those
this the particular sentences that zarin
was reading
i i i had a premonition of having to
account for our use of
of our categories in a graduate seminar
and so that moment has arrived right
um it's um it's opportunistic uh
um i mean i think both of us see um
uh the discourses of of of religion and
secularity
as as contested space and plural and
that they can be
carved up in any which way i think um
you know we have some schmidian
affinities and
and i think vincent has a vincent has a
really good
like a good kind of polemical uh
instincts
toward um toward dominant secularism
um that that i sponge off of
but i mean i think it's really
opportunistic right so uh in the in the
first chapter we talk about religion
i think we're talking about something in
abolitionism
like what we're saying like when we're
talking about abolition abolitionism
we're talking about something that in
the american tradition is like already
always already
religious and in its in its in its arter
uh you know and it's absolutism right as
as kinds of
affects that that that circulate around
around
religion as it's constituted and then
you know and then in the final chapter
it's like but let's look more
particularly for these kinds of
religious
forms and narrowly conceived but i i
again like i am um
i think that like if we think
ethnographically
again so in answer to your question
skyler about
this uh this acquiescence to christian
discourse
um uh if we think ethnographically
whether it's um a phenomenological or a
theological
um or even a you know a secular
anthropological
um although less so that um if we're
thinking about
americans and people who live in this
land they are operating with the
christian categories now
that is a problem and it and it as you
know
sylvister's work shows it uh it carries
with it
uh all sorts of dark unpassed histories
of domination
but it's also as far as we're seeing it
making an intervention into a discourse
that presents itself as largely secular
it's
an uh it's just an opportunity it's all
this low-hanging fruit right so
again that's what i when i say that
we're doing it opportunistically i don't
only mean that we're doing it sloppily
although i also mean that i i what i
mean is that we're doing it
because we want we we want to make a
contribution that is going to be useful
to build power
um i love how different your answers are
and yet they illuminate each other and
before we move to the next question i
actually
want to give sylvester a chance to
respond as well
because uh maybe as i uh secularism and
the secular
are not key themes in this book
sylvester but
i wonder um you know i know that you're
quite conversant with
the the sort of critical secularism
studies stuff
um and uh and i also see the book
african-american religions as something
of a uh
implicit challenge to secularization
narratives
and um and i wonder if you were to think
with critical secularism studies or
think with this kind of conversation
about the secular
how you would write that into this book
sure uh yeah so these are these are some
really i think enlightening questions
and
uh very important attention has been
devoted to these categories as critical
categories so as you noted
this i'm not i'm not after those
categories explicitly in this book
i am thinking about them and
one of the ways that i have that in mind
is with
the the the global
claims that are being made about the
nature of religion
uh during the the 16th 15th and 16th
we kind of go through all these
centuries 16 17th centuries
uh because the the book engages
at one point with what's often called
the history of
the fetish or fetishism the idea
uh that worshiping that having a
delusional perception
that things could do things
was the natural religion
of black people that that history of
making that claim
is a big part of the the racial history
of capital
that the book engages with and so
one of the important
forces that enables the
racialization of peoples who
come to be known as as black people or
the black race
in this set of histories is
made possible by uh
by claiming that they had this
delusional capacity
and this was in fact according to a
number of european
authors the original black religion the
quintessential black religion
was having this delusion
that things could do things and so that
was called animism or fetishism it
wasn't just black people particularly uh
aboriginal peoples australia
of the americas uh this was this claim
was made as well
and so one of the things that i try to
tease out in those histories
is how the category of religion itself
could mean different kinds of things and
in this instance one of
the things that categorization achieved
was
uh was racialization in another way i
try to show toward the end of the book
that that islam
becomes racialized uh not for the first
time this is
anyone who's studied the juridical
political history of
the principle of pse de sangre the idea
that jews and muslims could not belong
to the political community of the west
knows that this was this was not a new
invention
but certainly at the end of the 20th
century and then the 21st so-called
post-9 11 era
this becomes much more central to
securitization practices
and and so one of the things that i
think it's important to consider that i
was considering in finishing the book
was
was the need to understand uh the west
itself
as since it it exists
in its violent constitution by declaring
the muslim and the jew
and more recently particularly as as
extraneous
as being incapable of having a pristine
relationship
with the west which is supposed which is
most
frequently parsed as not a religious
type of
subjectivity but as a secular one
is actually indicative
of
the need to attend to how
what might seem to be something that's
not about religion i mean this is this
is an
old at this point critique of the
critical secularism studies
that secularism as it behaves and
actually functions is
not despite what the billboard or label
might say
is not the rejection of religion
uh it's it's a different set of
exercises that might well
take up religion in order to do certain
things and so i think that
those particular uh social histories
exemplify the importance of the numerous
ways that any
any number of scholars have tried to
show
that thinking of secularism as
something that is that's not religion
is actually very misleading uh even
something that's supposed to be so
circle so secular as being western
and i think the the racialization of
islam
uh in order to position muslims
as political enemies of the nation
states that are governed by white
governments
is especially emblematic of that
so it's it's not it's not at the surface
level but it is something that i was
thinking a lot about
uh this more implicit book
no i think i think it's definitely there
the co-constitution
comes through the argument for sure
sylvester okay so let's have one more
question from biko
hey everyone um it's good to see
sylvester and vincent
again it's good seeing joshu for the
first time um
this is a wonderful conversation i i've
been thinking a bit about this notion of
freedom and
breeding uh probably too much hegel and
so i'm
gonna put that up there up front but i'm
think i'm wondering if freedom
requires its opposite and so what i'm
thinking about in other words if
does justice require the unjust does the
good require
the evil does freedom require the
constrained part of this
is coming in certain ways from uh from
professor johnson's text
where i'm thinking about how a certain
freedom could be practiced
above the castles over and against the
bodies that were packed in the bottom
of those castles on the uh west african
shores and so
i don't mean to be the wrenchy guy like
but like sort of afro-pessimism is on my
mind and that there's a particular very
real
commitment to understanding that that
this world as it is constituted demands
a constitutive outside demands an
abject entity against which it must
define itself
such that if we think about these
concepts of freedom justice
and um goodness which is my category
what
essentially i'm wondering about is how
do we not how do we stave off the sort
of theodisian attempts
to define oneself over and against the
evil
define oneself as good as just as free
over and against whatever we understand
as the manikin sort of evil dimension of
that
i hope that makes sense but just to make
it real make it real
simple is there are there concepts of
freedom that do not require
the constraint um and i i i hear you
all and i'm i'm pushing just a little
bit against it and wondering
what happens when decarceration occurs
what happens
when we think about freedom so those are
the questions thank you
i mean on the hageli note there's a
wonderful article by bob brandum called
freedom and constraint by norms from the
late 70s american journal philosophy
american philosophical quarterly which
does a a really nice
uh job of you know uh saying you know
intuitively we think of freedom and
constrained as opposites but actually
if we think of something like poetry we
think of the way that
norms uh and constraint make poetry
possible
uh and uh i mean i think that's when
we're thinking of
tradition uh again in a sort of just our
influence way right tradition
is a set of norms that make possible uh
uh freedom right they make possible um
sort of creative expression and
flourishing uh
and i mean so uh
i mean on the one hand that that's a
positive sense of freedom
uh on the other hand uh at least i think
i would have
the apathetic uh stance with respect to
that right that's always
uh sort of uh over the over um
unreachable gap from the present
uh and you know in the in the road we
have uh
we have systems of domination that are
uh
interlocking and uh there's no path to
getting rid of them and yet there's
still an imperative to get rid of them
because over that gap is a sense of
freedom and we're motiva motivated
by that um to continue the struggle
because
we're embedded in in traditions of
struggle uh that that
uh prom that hold that promise uh
a genuine freedom
josh or sylvester do you want to take a
stab at that
great final question yeah thanks because
great to see you
as well thanks for joining us i i think
that
it's it's an important question to ask
and i
you know your question again reminds me
of
of one of the central tenets that
patterson makes
in his study of freedom
that has a social system social
political system
that freedom thrives particularly in
slave holding societies
and that it it is most highly venerated
in societies that have been most
fiercely and most thoroughly devoted to
slave holding
because then you have an identity uh
that there the freedom is
is for the free and and then there are
people who are not free
and so it's not just a system it's an
identity
i think beyond that within the context
of
of uh global empires and particularly
western empires
the idea of the west as being the land
of freedom-loving peoples
and the the non-western world as being
the space of tyranny i think
demonstrates the importance
of the identitarian formation of freedom
um so again
me being repetitive the caveat i'm not
claiming that if we can just get rid of
freedom the world would be a better
place that's absurd
that's not that would that would really
be
completely misunderstanding what the
problem actually is this is not a
language game
and it's it's certainly not that
that uh that freedom or even the
democracy is the problem per se if we
could just get rid of democracy
we'll be better off no we won't we'll be
stuck with the same set of problems that
we have we'll call it something else
but rather i think you i do think it's
helpful
to to not
at least for people who who appreciate
the importance
are not for people in order to
appreciate the importance of this to be
objectively for anyone
to appreciate the importance of what's
at stake in
understanding how these things are
related why we shouldn't think of
slavery as the opposite of freedom
uh which is not the same thing
by my intention to say that it doesn't
matter if you're enslaved if you're free
because you know these things are not
it's all the same stuff no it's it's
different degrees of being dominated and
there's thorough obligation to some how
thoroughly obligated are you to someone
and to what degree can you not be
obligated no one is completely free of
obligations
in fact it would make no sense we we
couldn't have a functional society in
which no one was obligated you know can
you imagine
driving your car you're on empty and you
go to swipe your bank card to put gas in
your car
and the bank says well we're not
actually obligated to honor
your bank card because we just don't
feel like it today
and uh you're you know you're a child
it's time to eat you're 12 years old you
come home from school and your parents
say well you know what we're
we're not really feeling obligated to be
parents today like
of course we need that system of
obligation would a language of
obligation be better
than the language of freedom or slavery
and i'm not necessarily i think we need
to accord
our systems our structures our practices
of resources with an understanding of
what we need to have the kind of
outcomes that are equitable and
and so that means uh you know to your
one
example joshua was giving was about uh
freedom meaning you shouldn't accident
have access to my income i don't want to
pay taxes i need to free my libertarian
dollars
from your greedy government well
realistically the only way you can have
a functioning society
is if there are all kinds of obligations
that we benefit from that cost
money so if you like having a legal
system that allows you to require real
estate
then you're depending on all kinds of
implementations of practices or or even
getting access to health care
and there has to be a way to pay for
that and
if you want these privileges guess what
you're obligated
to do sort of like marriage you're you
have to
give certain things in order to get
certain things
and that's just that's just
sociologically historically empirically
true but that truth
is elided by the way that we typically
talk
about freedom and slavery so
[Music]
does one require the other well
in the way that we have inherited an
understanding
of free yes it does and the idea that
there can be the free world
and then there are those other people
out there who are not western who are
not ruled by
predominantly white governments and
and they're not the free world even
though
we have overthrown in the united states
more democracies than anyone else we win
the trophy
and and and so if you're
if you're thinking about it from that
point i would say we've certainly
inherited
a way of interpreting the traditions of
freedom and slavery that treat them as
opposites and make them require each
other
but it certainly does not have to be
that way but it's not a matter of just
changing the language
it's about changing our policies and our
practices
yeah this is um so fantastic and i have
to say it
it was really incredible to read these
two books in this moment of
intersecting political crises and to
think with you i
i uh i have to say last week we wrote
the lal assad's
formations of the secular and he has a
you know kind of
long-standing suspicion as to of the
category of scholar activists and to
what extent
really uh those of us who work in the
academy are actually
helpful as like political critics or
political analysts in any given moment
any more than
the lay person uh what might be or the
you know
our students for example um but i have
to say it was
actually really uh incredible to be able
to think with these texts and the three
of you
um tonight and all of us together and um
i love what josh said about not ever
organizing a closet
um and but you know there's a kind of
bad on purpose aesthetic on youtube
that is uh or tic toc that's of the
moment i think sloppy on purpose is also
a tactic a political tactic
and i appreciate that and and so
really just want to thank you and you
this will also just say the same that
you know this was really uh invigorating
stimulating inspiring
and uh and and certainly um
a kind of call to action in many
different kinds of actions so thank you
all for being here and thank you
especially to our
authors for being with us yes i just
want to reiterate that
thanks and it's uh you know these are
two completely different books as we
started out by saying
but i think uh this discussion
um makes me feel like serena and i did
good impairing them so
but it's also testament to the the the
really the the
the depth of each of these books that
they can
uh be brought together in this kind of
interesting and engaging way so thank
you to
sylvester vincent and josh and thanks to
all of you for being
uh you know sticking with us and um
and being part of this conversation so
please join me in
um a round of um zoom applause
so thank you josh is offering his email
many of our students have more questions
i'm sure they'll be sending those two to
all
three of you this was really wonderful
thanks again and
it's great thanks so much thank you so
much
thank you bye bye